michel scarbonchi bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france on lisait le premier ministre
libyen abdel mahdi abeba donc prêté
serment hier pour commencer qu'est ce
qu'on connaît de cet homme qui avait été
désigné premier ministre par un terrible
début février on l'appelle d'abord il
est originaire de misrata
c'est un homme d'affaires très important
qu'à participer dès 2007 à la
reconstruction de la libye
donc sous kadhafi et qui était plutôt
liée à salif l islam le fils de kadhafi
c'est un homme qui a réussi à obtenir
devant l'assemblée nationale réuni à
syrte
présidée par monsieur ghislain salée
sans vote sur 130 parlementaires ce qui
démontre bien la volonté de benghazi et
tripoli et de misrata de faire durer cet
accord de paix qui vient d'être signé
donc vous avez maintenant aujourd'hui
monsieur menphis qui représente bengazi
que président du conseil présidentiel et
vous avez surtout monsieur date baïda
qui est premier ministre qu'est la
réalité du pouvoir dans les institutions
libyennes actuel alors telle que mise en
place en tout cas par l'onu alors c'est
vrai que alesi je vous en prie non c'est
un réel espoir 1 beaucoup doutent et moi
même d'ailleurs douter d'arriver à cet
accord politique
il a été adoubé par le match à la star
il était adoubé par toutes les parties
sauf peut-être monsieur sa rage l'ancien
premier ministre et monsieur fathi
bachagha l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur
il continue à se disputer à se battre et
tripoli mais pour l'essentiel il y a
vraiment une véritable volonté d'aller
vers l'avant une volonté de 1
réconcilier et libyens 1 qui se bat
depuis entre eux depuis maintenant onze
années il ne faut pas l'oublier depuis
que la france et la grande bretagne ont
déclenché sous mandat de l'onu cette
guerre absurde et donc l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est la réconciliation et
la reconstruction du pays
alors et je suis allée la réconciliation
et la reconstruction du pays
effectivement
il ya aussi beaucoup de force étrangère
en libye
on pense à la petite fille l'egypte les
émirats arabes unis des occidentaux
également la russie aussi est ce qu il
compte s'appuyer sur les uns ou les
autres où l'objectif est bien c'est
d'écarter toute ingérence écoutez le
premier ministre lui même qui est censé
être proche de la russie et de la
turquie vient de déclarer que ignol doit
plus y avoir en libye d'occupation
étrangère ni d'ingérence
donc il est lui même lucide sur le fait
que les forces étrangères doivent
quitter le pays
je pense que ankara et moscou vont
obtenir ce qu'elle souhaitait c'est à
dire avec tripoli avec bengazi la
présence de bord de base navale et la
présence de l'aérodrome militaire
c'est ce qu'elle souhaitait ces deux
pays souhaitait cela ou bien s'implanter
en méditerranée
donc ils vont l'obtenir cela après pour
le reste les les mercenaires de la
société wagner russes vont partir et je
pense que les troupes turques partiront
aussi on assiste aussi à un renouveau
dans les relations diplomatiques
notamment avec l'egypte qui n'est pas
rien oui oui tout à fait le premier
voyage de monsieur daldry bas le premier
ministre a été pour le mari shanxi si en
egypte ce qui démontre bien que le
premier ministre a l'intelligence de
comprendre que s'il veut réconcilier les
libyens il doit être à égale distance
des puissances étrangères qui ont
participé à ce conflit depuis des années
c'est à dire l'egypte les émirats arabes
unis la russie la turquie et donc il
fait des gestes qu'il faut pour montrer
sa réelle volonté de réconcilier et je
crois je crois que l'homme est sincère
l'homme est jeune il appartient à la
nouvelle génération libyenne n'oubliez
pas que vous êtes dans un pays où 46 %
de la population a moins de 26 ans est
donc maintenant il faut s'appeler à
l'essentiel c'est à dire avant de parler
d'élection il faut d'abord que la libye
est une constitution qu il
permettre d'organiser des élections vous
êtes dans un pays où il n'ya pas de code
électoral ou dans la constitution il
n'est pas prévu de président de la
république élu au suffrage universel
donc tout cela doit être fait sur la
base de la constitution existante et je
pense que ça va être la première tâche
du premier ministre dans les semaines
qui viennent
outre le fait que sur le plan économique
il doit s'atteler à mettre fin à l'
inflation galopante à mettre fin aux
pénuries d'électricité d'essence et donc
à ce que la libye retrouve sur le plan
économique et social
un semblant de vie normale oui vous le
rappeler effectivement on sait que le
quotidien est rude un poil à la
population libyenne cette population
selon vous elle va accorder sa confiance
à ce nouveau premier ministre
oui oui c'est des dix sortes
il faut nous oublions nous les européens
que la libye est en guerre depuis 2011
malgré les interventions de l'onu malgré
tout ce qui a été fait et c'est à ce
pays est en guerre depuis 2011
donc un pays de 2 6 millions 7 millions
d'habitants
ken rente pétrolière très importante qui
va lui permettre malgré les aides qui va
recevoir et grâce aux aides qui va
recevoir aussi de l'extérieur mais qui
va lui permettre de se redresser très
vite la libye a la capacité à se
développer et à se reconstruire
rapidement parce qu'elle en a les moyens
financière elle-même sans dépendre de la
banque mondiale sans dépendre du fmi etc
etc
alors c'est vrai que le premier ministre
a gelé hier aussi un tous les contrats
avec les puissances étrangères
vous parliez d'économie qu'est ce que ça
signifie mais ça signifie que vous avez
vous avez rien que sur le plan des
villes à reconstruire syrte syrte qui
est en train de devenir un petit peu la
capitale
equi distance égale de benghazi et de
tripoli et qui la ville de naissance de
mouammar kadhafi n'oubliez pas cette
ville de syrte est détruite à 90%
donc il faut la reconstruire idem pour
tobrouk
idem pour bernard 30% de bengazi tripoli
aussi
donc rien que sur le plan du logement
sur le plan des infrastructures
vous avez vous avez un chantier immense
immense en libye auxquels j'espère la
france pourra participer
merci beaucoup michel hins kharbouchi
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes ancien député
européen et consultant sur le
moyen-orient